[Музика]
привіт, хлопці, ласкаво просимо на наші уроки англійської мови.
Я дуже радий бачити вас сьогодні,
і ми продовжуємо говорити про роботу та
кар'єру,
хлопці, влаштуватися на роботу неможливо
без хорошої освіти чи підготовки до
кваліфікації, тому  Насправді я б сказав,
що освіта є ключем до відкриття
золотих дверей до вашої свободи або іноді
ви можете почути, що вони кажуть, що
освіта є ключем до успіху, я на 100%
погоджуюся з цим твердженням, і ви можете
побачити цю цитату Джорджа Вашингтона,
обкладинка та  якщо вам потрібно, ви можете
записати це, тому що, можливо, колись ця цитата
стане для вас мотиваційною, добре,
хлопці, перш ніж ми почнемо, нам, звичайно, потрібно
трохи словникового запасу, подивіться на правий
і лівий стовпці всі синоніми, давайте
переглянемо їх і зіставимо  синоніми,
тож перший стовпець та його
система звітів забезпечують аналіз грамотності,
важливий цінний величезний ключ і назви, а
тепер подивіться, будь ласка, на наступний
стовпець, і там є синоніми, щоб
синоніми були готові  ng та написання
необхідний метод важливий іспит
дослідження гігант дайте назви та назви, тому
всі слова дуже легкі, я думаю,
але завдання полягає в тому, щоб відповідати синонімам,
тому подивіться, у вас
є хвилина або близько того, і будь ласка, запишіть
свої відповіді на своїх аркушах паперу  або
у вашому полі для копій добре, так хвилинку, а
потім ми перевіримо відповіді добре, хлопці, я
сподіваюся, що ви готові перевірити свої
відповіді, давайте подивимося добре, тому
звіт означає дослідження, щоб ви могли сказати про
нещодавнє дослідження або  останній звіт про
освіту, наступне слово – це система, тож
синонімом є метод, ви можете сказати, що моя
система освіти або мої методи освіти
подібні до цього, то надавати це
означає надавати так надавати турботу або
піклуватися, щоб забезпечити освіту чи
дайте освіту добре наступне слово
аналізується аналізується означає перевіряється,
наприклад тести Ouray можна проаналізувати або
ваші здібності можна проаналізувати, або ви
можете бути перевірені, тому наступне слово -
грамотність грамотність - це навички, які ви не маєте
кваліфікації, які ви отримали в scho  ol вони
навички читання та письма,
якщо вміння читати, писати й
розуміти тексти добре, наступне є
необхідним, а слово-синонім
необхідне, ми можемо сказати, що освіта
необхідна в нашому житті, або ми можемо сказати, що
освіта необхідна в нашому житті, добре,
тоді приходить  цінний і синонім
дорогоцінний добре, хлопці, якщо є
деякі шанувальники Володаря кілець, тоді
ви побачите це слово дорогоцінний, чи пам'ятаєте ви
одного персонажа, про який там завжди говорилося
під час моєї дорогоцінні, добре, а
наступний величезний, а синонім
гігантський
добре, я намагався не говорити тільки великий або
великий намагайтеся використовувати інші прикметники, як-от
величезний або гігантський, добре,
тоді приходить ключ-ключ – це те, чим ви
відчиняєте двері, але якщо я говорю ключове
поняття, я маю на увазі, що це поняття
важливе або коли  Я кажу, що ключові
знання означають, що важливі знання добре,
а останнє — це назви, а
насправді синонім — імена добре, хлопці, тепер
ви готові до частини слухання, а
ви повинні вгадати, чи твердження
правдиві чи неправдиві, давайте переглянемо
ці твердження, тому, хлопці, ви збираєтеся
послухати про одну з найкращих систем
освіти – систему освіти
Фінляндії, і це буде коротка
радіопрограма про неї,
тож давайте переглянемо твердження та
зробимо ваші  прогнози перше, у
статті говориться, що освіта в дитячих садках у Фінляндії
є найкращою у світі, тому в
заяві йдеться, що дорогі дитячі
садки найкращі в світі, можливо, так,
можливо, ні, позначте це правда чи неправда,
тоді наш звіт на 50 сторінках розглянув
систему освіти 52
Звіт на 50 сторінках країн і 52 країни роблять ваш
прогноз, щоб ваш газ був в порядку, потім
дослідники переглянули
показники відвідуваності під час своїх досліджень,
це означає, що люди приходять
до школи чи ні, і яка швидкість їхнього приходу до школи, потім D Мексика та
Бразилія  були в топ-50 країн,
можливо, ці країни Латинської
Америки потрапили в топ-50, тоді потрібно
послухати та перевірити свій прогноз
у звіті надано п'ять пропозицій
для тих, хто приймає рішення в галузі освіти, п'ять
пропозицій для тих, хто вирішує,
якою освітою буде сама освіта
в майбутньому, якщо у
звіті говориться, що витрачати більше грошей
означатиме кращу освіту, більше грошей,
кращу освіту або  чи насправді нам
потрібно багато грошей, щоб мати хороших вчителів,
хороші школи і так далі, ви повинні
прислухатися та перевірити свій прогноз G у
звіті говориться, що батьки повинні триматися подалі
від шкіл та вчителів Я вважаю,
що це чудова мрія багатьох вчителів,
директорів та вихователів  що батьки
не будуть втручатися
добре, хлопці, це хороша ідея, тому
прослухайте звіт і скажіть «правда чи неправда», а
останнє з них говорить про те, що ми не знаємо,
які вакансії будуть у майбутньому,
так що твердження правдиве  ваші
прогнози добре, хлопці, я хочу
сьогодні щось інше, тому я покажу
вам відповіді перед прослуховуванням,
подивіться ось відповіді добре,
правильні речення зелені та
неправильні речення червоні, тому ось
відповіді, які ви можете скопіювати, ммм, я не дуже
хороший учень, я знову зробив три помилки,
хлопці, у цих відповідях є
три помилки, добре, хлопці, ви повинні
послухати, і ви повинні знайти мої три
помилки  чи готові ви слухати, добре, у
Фінляндії найкраща у світі освітня
система, це останні новини. Англійська
затишшя нова доповідь про світову освіту
показує, що у Фінляндії найкраща система
глобальне дослідження називається
кривою навчання та взято з британського журналу
The Economist, яке прагне допомогти
уряди забезпечують кращу
освіту студентам. У звіті на 52 сторінках
розглядається освітня система в 50 країнах.
Дослідники проаналізували мільйони
статистичних даних про рівень відвідуваності іспитів, рівень грамотності
та рівень закінчення університетів.
третє, четверте
і п'яте, Сполучені Штати посіли 17 місце
в дослідженні, а Мексика, Бразилія та
Індонезія, зайняли нижнє місце  ee
позиції в топ-50.
Крива навчання повідомляє про п'ять речей, про які
керівники освіти повинні пам'ятати, по-
перше, що витрачати багато грошей на
школи та вчителів не завжди
означає, що учні дізнаються, по-друге,
хороші вчителі мають важливе значення для
високоякісної освіти.  що до
вчителів слід ставитися як до їх
цінних професіоналів, вони не є
техніками у величезній освітній
машині. 3 і 4 полягає в тому
, що культура країни має бути
зосереджена на важливості освіти, а
батьки відіграють ключову роль,
нарешті, країни повинні
навчати майбутнього, а не лише сьогодення. У
звіті сказано, що багатьох сучасних посад
просто не існувало 20 років тому добре,
хлопці, тож чи знайшли ви мої помилки, я
сподіваюся, що так,
давайте добре перевіримо перше твердження
хибне, у тексті сказано, що
відомий дитячий садок в
освіті хороший, але не вказано,
що він є в усьому світі, потім приходить наступний
, це твердження невірне насправді
b  тому що неможливо мати лише 50-
сторінковий звіт для 52 країн, добре,
наступний, будь ласка,
і це правда, вони дивилися на
показники відвідуваності під час дослідження,
це були важливі цифри, добре,
тоді це Мексика та Бразилія, вони
в 50 найкращих країнах, так, вони є  тож,
можливо, якщо ви хочете отримати хорошу
освіту, вам варто піти кудись там,
а потім у звіті є п’ять
пропозицій, і твердження є правдивим,
тому причина, коли ми створюємо звіти, полягає в тому, що
ми хочемо щось додати, ми
шукаємо інформацію, а потім приходимо  Отримавши
цю інформацію, ми прийшли з новими
ідеями, а в наступному твердженнях
у звіті йдеться, що витрачати більше грошей буде
означати освіту, і насправді це
неправда,
ви можете мати багато грошей, але ви можете
не знайти хороших вчителів, або у вас може бути
багато грошей  але учні не
мотивовані добре, потім наступне
речення, і це фальшиві батьки
не повинні триматися подалі від шкіл, а
вчителі повинні мати діалог
між t  кожен, батьки та
діти, звісно, останнє тв
рдження вірно, тому, хлопці, як ви помітили мої тр
помилки, я сподіваюся, що ви добре впоралися із за
данням, давайте продовжимо добре, давайте по
лухаємо ще раз і будь ласка, будьте готові ві
повісти на запитання, пе
егляньте  запитання та будьте готові до прослуховування,
тому перше запитання, яким був новий
звіт за терміном, це означає,
що таке звіт про назву звіту,
ви повинні прослухати точну
назву звіту, а потім
що читати зробили дослідники
подивіться, які два пункти
дослідники зібрали дані з наступного
, в якому положенні Південна Корея
закінчила в списку, можливо, першою, можливо,
третьою, можливо, п’ятою, ви повинні
послухати і зібрати цю інформацію,
наступну, про що була позиція Мексики
список, щоб ви знали, що він входить до п’ятдесяти найкращих,
послухайте точну кількість, а потім
з’явиться, скільки речей у звіті
хотілося б, щоб керівники освіти пам’ятали, ви
знаєте цю відповідь з попереднього t  запитайте
, звичайно, ви були уважні наступного
, які хороші вчителі необхідні,
щоб пам’ятати це слово істотно
означає необхідне і як
не слід поводитися з вчителями, так як вчителі
не хочуть, щоб з ними ставилися батьки
чи діти  добре, наступне питання, на чому
культура
країни має бути зосереджена на чомусь, країна повинна зосередитися на
чомусь, і цей фокус має бути
дійсно сильним і прямим,
і останнє питання, що говориться у звіті
про багато посад сьогодні,
прослухайте ще раз і спробуйте відповісти  відповіді на ці
питання мають бути справді
короткими. У Фінляндії найкраща у світі система освіти,
це останні новини. Англійська
затишшя нова доповідь про світову освіту
показує, що у Фінляндії найкраща система
глобальне дослідження називається
кривою навчання та береться з британського журналу
The Economist, на яке воно спрямоване  Щоб допомогти
урядам забезпечити кращу
освіту студентам, у звіті на 52 сторінках розглядається
система освіти в 50 країнах,
дослідники аналізують  ed мільйони
статистичних даних про рівень відвідуваності іспитів грамотності
та рівень закінчення університетів
Азія показала хороші результати у звіті: Південна
Корея Гонконг, Японія та Сінгапур
посіли 2-е, 3-е, 4-е та 5-е місце, Сполучені
Штати посіли 17-е місце в дослідженні, а
Мексика, Бразилія та Індонезія заповнили
нижню частину  На трьох позиціях у топ-50
крива навчання повідомляє про п'ять
речей, які керівники освіти мають
пам'ятати, перше, що витрачати
багато грошей на школи та вчителів
не завжди означає, що учні навчаться, по-
друге, що хороші вчителі
необхідні для високоякісної освіти.
звіти про те, що до вчителів слід ставитися
як до їх цінних професіоналів, вони
не є техніками у величезній освітній
машині № 3 і 4, що
культура країни має бути
зосереджена на важливості освіти, а
батьки відіграють ключову роль,
нарешті, потреби країн  щоб
навчати майбутнього, а не тільки теперішнього, у
звіті сказано, що багато сучасних назв посад
просто d  id не існувало 20 років тому
добре, хлопці, ви слухали їжу
вдруге, тепер давайте перевіримо відповіді
добре, тому відповідь на перше питання
- це світова освіта, тож це означає освіту
в усьому світі, тому друге -
це крива навчання  на графіку
добре,
потім іде номер третій рівень грамотності
та рівень закінчення університетів,
існує зв’язок між грамотністю, це означає,
наскільки добре люди вміють читати і писати, і
якщо вони закінчують університети, якщо вони
закінчують університети, то
на якій позиції закінчила Південна Корея
у списку вони були на другому місці, добре,
а номер п'ятий він був у
трійці останніх, так, хоча вони
були 50 найкращими освітніми системами, вони були
в трійці останніх, все одно хороший результат,
а потім номер сім, які хороші
вчителі необхідні для хороших вчителів,
важливі для  якісна освіта, ви
не можете отримати високоякісну освіту
без професійного та якісного
вчителя, тоді як не повинно
бути вчителів  до вчителів не слід
ставитися як до техніків, а наступне
те, на що культура країни має бути
зосереджена, і це
важливість освіти, якщо країна приділяє багато
уваги своїй освіті, тоді
нація стає сильнішою і останньою
їх не існувало 20 років тому, тому
ринок праці змінюється, і в майбутньому у нас
будуть зовсім інші роботи.
Привіт, хлопці, ви слухали це, і
ви готові продовжувати, тому я хочу
навести вам чотири основні причини, чому
освіта є  ключ до успіху – це
мої причини, і вони лише для того, можливо,
ви можете додати ще кілька до цього списку, і
я впевнений, що існує більше
ніж чотири причини, чому
важливо вчитися, тому моя перша
причина полягає в тому, що освіта  допомагає вам отримати
особистий контроль над своїм життям, тому це
означає, що під час навчання ви
навчитеся керувати своїм життям, ви
навчитеся швидко приймати рішення, ви дізнаєтесь
про все, що є в основному в світі, і
ви можете зосередитися на полі  більше
знань, що вас дійсно цікавить,
моя наступна причина полягає в тому, що це допомагає зробити
світ кращим,
ви знаєте, коли хтось думає про
бізнес, ідея полягає не тільки в
грошах, ідея полягає в
тому, чому вони потрібні людям, чому я маю це зробити,
можливо, і  насправді має бути, що
ваш бізнес або ваша робота допомагають цьому
світу стати кращим,
наприклад, якщо я вчитель, я хочу
викладати якнайкраще,
це означає, що я ходжу на різні
курси, я читаю книги, з якими співпрацюю
викладачі по всьому світу, і я
намагаюся зробити свої заняття цікавими, якщо я роблю
свої заняття цікавими, я роблю своїх
студентів сильнішими в знаннях і
навичках, і якщо вони сильніші в
знаннях і навичках, то є
кращі професіонали, якщо є кращі
професіонали, вони краще виконують свою роботу
і  це дуже корисно, це дуже
добре для країни та для світу,
добре, наступна освіта дозволяє
втілити ваші мрії в реальність,
це найкраще поєднання, якщо ви можете
розчесати  у вашій роботі та вашому хобі,
наприклад, у вас є талант до малювання, або у
вас є талант у танцях, або у вас є
талант у математиці, перетворите своє
хобі на пошук роботи.
Ваша робота не буде просто
обов’язковими дев’ять-п’ятьма годинами, які ви
будете веселитися, і ви будете насолоджуватися кожною
хвилиною, тому що ви будете працювати у
сфері, яка вам справді подобається, і дуже
важливим аспектом є те, що це дає вам
підвищена спроможність заробляти, якщо ви маєте
високу кваліфікацію, якщо ви хороший
професіонал, вам будуть платити більше, і,
звичайно, це відкриє вам більше дверей
і відкриє ваші нові шляхи, добре
хлопці, тому щоб краще володіти англійською, вам
потрібен граматичний перекус  ми повернулися з нашими
шансами та переглядом шансів, тому сьогодні
ми збираємося переглянути теперішнє просте та
Present Continue, ви повинні пам’ятати
це з попереднього рядка,
оскільки ми мали швидкий огляд на
це так просто, як правило, для фактів
та загальних даних  правда щось та  це
справді правда і відбувається щодня,
як англійці люблять футбол,
а потім звички та розпорядок дня я ходжу до школи
щодня я мию руки 20 разів на день,
тому це означає, що це моя рутина, вони
грають у футбол кожен день я мию руки
щодня  наступний сказав: використовуйте
програми для мурашок, у вас є уроки англійської мови
по середах, четвергах і п'ятницях,
тому чемпіонат світу почнеться в червні, добре,
наступний знову присутній безперервно,
але цей подарунок відбувається зараз
я стою, ви сидите я  Я говорю,
ти слухаєш добре, тоді буде фіксований
майбутній вечір цього вечора. Я
дивлюся Netflix і розважаюся зі своєю
сім’єю, або ми граємо у футбол зі
Смітом у суботу, і остання
критика – це коли ти хочеш
критикувати, а ти  дратується
чиїмись діями, о, він завжди
говорить неправду, о, він завжди спізнюється,
о, він завжди грає в теніс замість
футболу. Іншим аспектом цього є
дієслова стану та дієслова дії деякі дієслова, які
ми не можемо використовувати в  безперервна форма вони
є дієсловами стану вони є нашими
почуттями,
тому вони є нашими відчуттями, наші емоції та
наш стан серед них є такі
дієслова, як love hate own sensposed
та пахне це погано пахне, наприклад, і
ви можете побачити приклади stative
дієслова на екрані якщо ви дивитеся на
нас на YouTube, роздрукуйте цю сторінку, і
ви отримаєте ці дієслова на свій
комп'ютер,
ви не можете сказати, що мені потрібен новий телефон
, ви повинні сказати, що мені потрібен новий телефон,
і ви можете"  t кажу, що вони здаються втомленими
ні, вони здаються втомленими, це стан, у який ви
не можете цього зробити, ви можете бути таким або просто
не бути таким, добре, і,
звичайно, є дієслова дії та всі інші
дієслова, вони діють, якщо ви можете  зробіть це,
якщо ви можете написати, якщо ви вмієте читати, так
що це дія, тоді його можна використовувати в
безперервному теперішньому часі, тому приклад
виглядає так, наприклад, з ким він танцював,
щоб танцювати це дія або я
читав цю книгу, читаючи це
дія добре, давайте подивимося, давайте подивимося на
це та  ble і є щось
цікаве. Деякі дієслова стану можуть використовуватися
в безперервній формі, коли вони означають
дію, наприклад, у мене є комп'ютер, це
означає, що я володію комп'ютером, це стан, у
мене він або у мене його немає, але якщо я
скажи, що я снідаю,
снідати означає їсти, а потім це
перетворюється на дію, яку ви бачите, чи
є у вас машина, чи є у вас автомобіль, або
в активному значенні вони
вечеряють зараз, це означає, що вони їдять
тоді виходить, що ти мій найкращий друг,
це факт, тож це може бути справжньою чи хибною
примхою, але це факт, що це не дія,
а речення там: вона знову
дурна, що
означає, що вона знову поводиться дурно,
вона не дурна, вона просто
щось робить  безглуздий наступний, що суп
добре пахне Миш, який я відчуваю, і він
хороший, тому він має хороший запах, але якщо я
чую щось наче я нюхаю його
, це означає, що він відчуває
запах супу, різниця пахне, як пахне троянда
або я можу відчути запах троянди
наступної  молоко на смак кисле я
випив молока і воно кисле
я більше не хочу його пити і
навпаки, я куштував їжу,
тож це дія я взяв ложку і
я щось скуштував, а ось
інші дієслова  які можна перевести із
стану в дію, будь ласка, подивіться
та погляньте на цю вправу. Привіт, хлопці, давайте подивимося,
давайте виконаємо цю вправу, ви повинні вказати,
чи це альфа, добре, хлопці, давайте виконаємо
цю вправу, ви повинні закреслити
неправильні відповіді, щоб завершити  У наступних
реченнях ви повинні вирішити, чи
є це дієслово стану чи дієслово дії,
давайте подивимося на перше, на мою
думку, де, на мою думку, фільм був
дійсно гарним, виберіть відповідь,
наступне з’єднатися чи є некорисним у
момент подумайте трохи, чи це дія чи
це стан, як вам подобається чи як
вам подобається новий дім, щоб освітлити це,
безумовно, стан, тому що вам подобається чи
вам просто не подобається, тоді приходить я не
бачу я  Я не розумію, як ми можемо так
виграти цю гру  Я не бачу, я не
розумію, це стан, чи я не
кажу, ніби я дивлюся, чи можете ви використовувати це,
як це, подумайте, що номер п'ять Грег бачить або
зустрічається з новою дівчиною, тож це означає, що
він зустрічається  або
він розуміє нову дівчину наступну,
ти виглядаєш розгубленим,
що ти думаєш про що ти думаєш, це дія
чи це маєток, тоді приходить Педро та
Тіна є або є дуже креативними
людьми, щоб бути творчою особистістю чи це
дія  чи це стан, потім приходить
Джеремі не усвідомлює чи не
усвідомлює усвідомити означає зрозуміти
, щоб зрозуміти, це дія чи
це стан, давайте подивимося добре, хлопці,
готові побачити відповіді, давайте подивимося, тому
першим має бути  Я думаю, оскільки
ви висловлюєте свою думку, наступна думка
є дуже некорисною, вона поводиться так,
а потім приходить, як вам подобається або
вам подобається, вам подобається це стан,
просто не думайте про інші варіанти, мені
подобається це  стан Я не бачу це означає, що я
не розумію льоду, це мій стан, якого я
не знаю  розумію, я не бачу причин я
не бачу сенсу, наприклад, номер 5
Грег каже, що це означає дію, яку він
зустрічає зі своєю дівчиною, наприклад, я можу сказати,
що я зустрічаюся з друзями сьогодні ввечері, це означає, що у мене є якісь позиції з моїми
друзями  потім приходить число 6 і про що
ти думаєш, щоб людина
сидить і думає про своє у
своїх думках, або вона в своїх думках, так
що Протея виконує дію,
наступне місце, де Педро і Тіна
мають бути творчими, це стан  це не
дія, ви креативні або ви не
креативні, наступне не розумієте,
означає розуміти, і знову ви
або розумієте, або ви не
розумієте добре хлопці, досить складне
завдання, я сподіваюся, що ви готові до
дому  киньте
і насправді домашнє завдання —
відповісти на ці запитання, які ви можете побачити
на екрані, тож тітонька Саксонія в Instagram
давайте проведемо яскраву дискусію, тому слідкуйте за
оновленнями та насолоджуйтеся англійською
[музикою]
вам